[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre sur tv soixante
dix huit pour un nouvel entretien
politique invitée aujourd'hui arnaud
péricard le maire de à
saint-germain-en-laye bonjour bonjour
vous venez d'être nommé référent
ile-de-france pour horizon c'est la
formation politique lancé par edouard
philippe vous allez plus
particulièrement à piloter
l'organisation du parti sur l'ouest
francilien tout d'abord avant de rentrer
dans le détail plus plus local plus
généralement pourquoi une nouvelle
formation politique
parce que je crois qu edouard philippe
avec un certain nombre d'autres non
autour de lui en donner nous allons
réunir à fontainebleau à la fin du mois
d'août voilà de merde de droite de
centre droit qui ne se retrouvera
peut-être dans les hommes politiques
du moment et qui ont à coeur de faire
valoir leurs idées dans un sip et
surtout une manière de faire de la
politique et je crois que ce qui est
très important et très intéressant
celles et ceux qui connaissent un peu
l'action d'edouard philippe c'est cette
manière que telle ne pas se laisser
enfermer dans un certain nombre de
petites phrases en un petit peu
d'auteurs un petit peu de dépassements
la politique ça ne peut pas être que
l'abattement un petit peu stérile et
services et aussi de temps en temps
prendre le temps de faire les choses
bien et donnait faire peut-être parfois
comme le dit souvent et leur clip de
faire les choses sérieusement sans trop
se prendre au sérieux le positionnement
ca centre droit pour autant le but c'est
de ne pas concurrencer en marche en
marche est une formation à part entière
qui est également une nouvelle formation
politique la plupart d'entre eux
deviennent attendant la plupart d'entre
nous sont d'ailleurs des anciens
républicains nous étions nombre de l et
r 2 déduire pierre vous savez j'ai à
coeur de rappeler que ma carte du rpr je
les lis le jour de mes 16 ans et
aujourd'hui l'on trouve qu'ils manquent
eux dans cette famille politique on se
retrouve pas l'offre politique n'est pas
une méthode les valeurs sont défendus ne
sont pas les mêmes un exemple qui me
tient à coeur c'est celle notamment du
libéralisme économique
et je trouve que voilà aveux sous le
quinquennat d'emmanuel macro est pris
particulièrement trouvé trois années où
elle n'aurait pas été prêt ministre avec
vous dans l'eau mais on l'a fait le
droit de réponse de la droite n'avait
jamais réussi à chiper on a privatisé de
l'entreprise on a l'idée en a libéré on
est puisque l'action de terre
d'investissement on est redevenu
attractif nombre d'entreprises
étrangères on a supprimé la peau de
solidarité sur la fortune donc voilà que
je me reconnais avant tout danser torse
qui étaient faits le prévenu économies
que nous ne retrouve plus vraiment dans
les débats idéologiques
moi je suis plus membre de l'ump depuis
environ cinq années je revendique et
j'assume ma liberté mais je me je me je
me retrouve assez bien dans le combat
politique que souhaite mener de leur
fils et il n'y aura aucune concurrence
il y aura un plein soutien à emmanuel
macron durant la campagne présidentielle
alors écoutez moi je crois qu'il faut là
aussi respecter les principes de liberté
un certain nombre d'entre vous ont
d'ores et déjà pris position et
d'enfiler de la paix je n'ai fait
également d'autres l'ont fait de ne
l'ont pas encore fait d'autres sont
fondées nord philippe tout en étant
parfois peut-être un petit peu éloigné
du soutien et milieu makoun breuty plus
réputés les vitesses d'intégration une
consolidation des uns et des autres ce
que je sens sur le territoire depuis que
nous avons lancé horizon c'est une très
forte demande dans quasiment toutes les
communes en tout cas de gimont mon voie
créée ici et là mais des comités locaux
la personnalité de notre idée est une
personnalité moratti qui intéresse ce
qui fascine beaucoup de personnalités
ont envie de faire de la politique
autour d'eux donc ce qui nous allons
faire dans les semaines dans les mois il
s'est organisé structuré c'est la
mission que nous a confié noir et
comment ça va se passer justement la
structuration sur l'ouest francilien
alors on est effectivement
il y a un différend juste pour revient
un peu sur l'organisation nationale il
ya un différend par région la
particularité de l'île de france et que
on à aller plus d'un million d'habitants
ça fait quasiment trois régions et donc
avec frédéric d'atouts pour skill
régional maire de fontainebleau delphine
bertille la maire du 9e arrondissement
qui poursuit régional également appris
on s'était bâti un petit peu de travail
et moi monde ces deux structures et
c'est à présent sur les dix villes de
seine et le val d'oise donc structuré ça
veut dire quoi wilfrid ça veut dire
simplement
organiser des comités locaux implantés
recruter ferney la légion aller voir
l'un des lieux et moite de la démarche
que la nôtre et la brague organiser les
futures élections
législatives dans tous ses départements
également donc voilà c'est ça une
stratégie d'implantation une formation
politique nouvelle oui en ligne de mire
il ya ces élections légistatives le
positionnement dans cette formation
politique c'est les législatives ya les
élections --législatives à ces clubs
l'objectif d'une formation politique sur
voilà tous les départements franciliens
et plus particulièrement paris donc le
moment venu une fois que cette élection
présidentielle sera derrière nous on
peut être un petit peu avant il sera
toujours mon travail d'andré déjà dans
cette stratégie d'implantation sur les
futurs d'élections législatives bien
évidemment avec des élections
législatives où on pourra avoir des
listes horizons en concurrence avec des
listes modem des listes en mars où
l'objectif c'est de faire une maison
commune
des candidats avec avec des suppléants
donc écouter pour le moment l'objectif
c'est pas a tempêté les uns et les
autres c'est de travailler sur la
complémentarité c'est de voir celles et
ceux qui ont déjà il n'y a pas de droits
acquis ou renouvellement d'un mandat je
ne souhaitais pas si un certain nombre
de parlementaires souhaitent renouveler
ou a souhaité se représenter aux
élections et 10,1 pour l'ensemble des
territoires de ludo pin se tiendra en
temps et en heure de faire un premier
bilan de voir quels sont les candidats
au city qui souhaite porter les couleurs
de de l'horizon et tout ça appartient
vous imaginez bien évidemment d'accord
mais il faudra d'abord tirer les
enseignements de cette élection
présidentielle
comment se porte la maison commune
aujourd'hui la maison commune c'est
cette maison cet ensemble politique qui
doit et qui devait en tout cas regroupés
en mars le modem horizons aussi et on
sait que ces dernières heures ces
derniers jours la situation était plutôt
compliqué edouard philippe a mis un
petit peu le frein parce que des fusions
ne pouvait pas se faire avec le groupe
agir notamment inquiets de gamme à cette
question là il y avait un principe on
sans rentrer dans les complexités trop
politicienne ce que je pense que ça
intéresse en fait très peu de de
personnes avaient un principe de
rapprochement entre formations
politiques et principe et dans la dans
la dans la maison commune londres
aujourd'hui il ya des orientations
différentes qui ont été et qui ont été
prises alors simplement leur trend
maison commune ils datent pas quelques
toujours cela fait déjà plusieurs
semaines qu'il ne se passe pas grand
chose dans cette maison commune et comme
il ne se passe pas grand chose je crois
que celle de ceux qui ont envie de
concourir à la réduction du président de
la république bat notre endroit main
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait horizons se
pare d'un et continue son développement
et continue justement à
militer sont émises et à se structurer
pour justement ne pas perdre de temps
par rapport à cet objectif là qu'est
l'élection de présidentielle l'oréal
l'achitecture commune l'ensemble comme
un tout et si les gens ont envie de
partager des choses horizon évidemment
on peut le faire mais très objectivement
et les cendres de bois au coude oui je
passe pas grand chose dans la maison
commune aujourd'hui quel positionnement
pour horizon par rapport aux nerfs
aujourd'hui par rapport à la candidature
de valérie pécresse avec qui vous êtes
plutôt bienveillant vous dites qu'une
partie de ces idées peuvent se retrouver
se retrouve aussi dans celle d'edouard
philippe alors écoutez moi j'ai toujours
eu déjà la plus grande amitié pour
valérie pécresse j'ai connu valérie elle
n'était pas encore député de la
circonscription des liens donc on se
connaît depuis longtemps les soutenu
fortement pour les élections régionales
je n'ai eu aucune difficulté à assumer
le choix qui est le mien aujourd'hui de
soutenir emmanuel macron je lui dis est
le comprends je lui dis également à ses
proches chaque élection a sa
particularité
hassar elle a sa vérité est ce que ça
veut dire que valérie pécresse ne sera
pas un jour président de république
d'irlande a énormément de qualités mais
aujourd'hui mon engagement et ma loyauté
vente représente la république qui à
edouard philippe on a un corpus
idéologique en commun et voilà la vérité
qui est vrai c'est qu'il a soutenu alain
juppé il ya cinq ans et qui partagent
des idéaux de droite de centre-droit
humaniste pro européen voila j'aimerais
bien là pour le coup véritablement la
retrouver on sent bien aujourd'hui
qu'elle est prise en deux tables avec
des personnalités qu'elle a combattu et
qu'elle a gagné dès qu'elle a vaincue
dans le cadre de cette de ce congrès ou
de cette primaire mais je crois que le
grand écart idéologique au sein de cette
famille politique qui élève les plus
durables voilà je pense que cette
qualification devrait intervenir est-ce
qu'elle intervient avant une élection
présidentielle est ce qu elle intervient
voilà mais pas nicolas sarkozy anac
chirac qui veut je pense qu'aujourd'hui
il ya trop d'écarts il ya trop de
différences au sein de cette famille
politique pour qu'elle puisse en tout
cas avoir un coeur de penser qu'ils
puissent parler à des gens comme moi ont
beaucoup d'autres dans ce département
voilà qui se sont enfuis on n'en pouvait
plus de ses discours démagogiques et de
cette ligne politique claire qu'il avait
plus de consistance que ce soit
françois-xavier bellamy que ce soit eric
ciotti nadine morano gilles platret
voilà moi je suis très très très éloigné
de tous les gens là et je souhaite me
retrouver dans une famille politique qui
me ressemble et à laquelle je ressors
vous avez mentionné le nom de jacques
chirac justement en 1976 jacques chirac
après avoir quitté matignon il fondait
le rpr il n'a eu de cesse de se battre
ensuite contre l'udf de valéry giscard
d'estaing votre père michel péricard
avait soutenu jacques chirac this te
ment au développement le rpr dans les
yvelines est-ce que l'histoire va se
répéter
coûté irène le voilà il ya des liens du
chili d'études c'est vrai que comme on
perd on perd devient mère de son enfant
né en 1977 les députés juste après et
jacques chirac lui avait confié la
mission en 1976 d'inventer les airs sur
des terres du dtp celles effectivement
des yvelines et il s'en est suivi une
implantation de personnalités politiques
importantes de ce département j'ai
arraché face de la rue pierre v10 les
enfants meurent à henri cuq à toutes
celles et ceux qui ont rigolé
politiquement pour le compte du rpr et
après de l'épée dans ce département je
sais pas si l'histoire à se répéter ce
que je sais est que je vois le nombre la
rmn toujours soir à la suite de la
création de de l'organisation d'horizon
c'est que je pense que horizon sur le
territoire des yvelines des
hauts-de-seine et dubai world a la
possibilité à la capacité d'être
peut-être une des toutes premières
formations politiques de ces
départements et de villes de france je
suis très motivé en tout cas pour faire
avancer cette formation
politique c'est toute l'ambition que
l'homme porte donc pour conclure il ya
un soutien qui est apportée au président
sortant et qui leur a déclaré sa
candidature tout en entendant pesé avec
vos propres thématiques et votre propre
formation politique moi j'ai toujours à
manquer ma liberté celle de ceux qui me
connaissent savent que je suis quelqu'un
de libre cela ne m'empêche pas de dire y
compris m et annie ce que je pense voilà
je le dis toujours et ça sera toujours
ma ligne de conduite voilà sept cette
sincérité c'est en chine cette
transparence quels que soient les
soutiens ça peut m'arriver de dire
également aux prisons la république ou
encore ce type ou à d'autres ceux qui
dépensent donc c'est ma marque de
fabrique en tout cas c'est celle que je
revendique et on peut être loyal tout en
étant effectivement désireux
d'accompagner le développement d'une
grande formation de droite et de
centre-droit assis sur des élus locaux
qui pèse beaucoup de domaines il ya
l'assemblée des maires de des horizons
qui va se structurer à la fin de la
famille ou du mois de janvier c'est une
nouvelle manière de faire de la
politique et c'est surtout une manière
tu as baiser de faire de la politique la
politique ça peut pas être que du
conflit permanent c'est aussi de temps
en temps comme on
comme on le dirait avec cet imam on pose
le crayon on réfléchit et surtout on se
respectent les uns les autres merci
beaucoup arnaud péricard maire de hem
saint germain en laye référent
ile-de-france du parti horizon donc
formation politique d'edouard philippe
on se retrouve bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]